[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH THOMSON:
Thanks for coming.
Really excited to
have you all here.
And I'm super stoked to have
this awesome panel here.
We have a fantastic
cross-section,
a really diverse
collection of indies
up here on the stage today.
First of all, my name is
Sarah, and I head up the Indies
Community for Google Play.
Really happy to be here
with Google this year.
And let's start off
with some intros.
Let's start here, Petr.
PETR VODAK: Hello.
My name is Petr Vodak.
I'm from Czech Republic, Prague.
I'm CEO and co-founder of
company called About Fun.
And we are mobile
game developers.
Right now 22 people.
And I'll be talking more
about our experience
with the publishers, LXS,
and some more crazy things.
JESSE SCHELL: Hi,
I'm Jesse Schell,
the CEO of Schell Games.
We've got a largish studio in
Pittsburgh, about 100 people,
doing everything from mobile
to interactive installations
and doing a lot of
VR and AR right now.
RICARDO FISCHER: Hi, everybody.
I'm Ricardo Fischer.
I'm director of
development at 505 Games.
We're a global
publisher really focused
on helping indies
bring games to market.
WILL TURNBULL: I'm Will Turnbull
from Klei Entertainment.
Klei Entertainment is a studio
of 60 people in Vancouver.
We do four indie games right
now, the most popular of which
is "Don't Starve."
And we focus on premium games.
PETE ARDEN: And I'm Pete
Arden from Disruptor Beam.
I'm the CMO there.
We're a Boston-based
publisher and developer
of licensed games, so games like
"Game of Thrones Ascent," "Star
Trek Timelines."
I'm responsible for the
publishing operations,
everything from acquiring users
through community to player
support.
SARAH THOMSON: Great.
Thanks, guys.
So how many of you are currently
developing for Android?
Great.
And how many are on the
fence thinking about it?
Considering it?
OK, great.
So let's maybe talk about
the fact that many of you,
if not all of you here,
have been developing games
for a number of years.
You've been in the industry
for quite some time.
You've kind of seen it all.
So what does mobile look
like these days for an indie?
Whoever wants to start that off.
JESSE SCHELL: It's
so hard, oh my god.
[CHUCKLING]
It is not an easy thing, right?
There was a time when mobile
was this exploding phenomenon.
And there was just rapid growth.
And people were spending crazy
amounts of money on apps.
And that time is not
happening right now, right?
So it means that if--
I guess from what I'm
seeing as an indie--
if you are doing
traditional things--
and by traditional things, I
mean ideas that are like two
years old or older--
then you have to have
something pretty clever.
And you have to have a nice
hook to your community.
Or you need to just be doing
something very different.
That's part of the reason
we're doing a lot of VR and AR
and Tango and things is because
we see that as a growth area.
RICARDO FISCHER: Yeah, I'd
have to agree that it's changed
a lot in the last 17 years.
I started.
I worked with
[? Autumn ?] for a while.
And there was a very different
landscape at the time.
Right now, it's
ultra competitive.
It is hard to get visibility.
And I think if you're
depending on getting featured,
you may end up
being disappointed.
I think Google makes a great
effort to feature great games.
But the case is,
is not everybody
is going to land there.
So you're going to have
to find your own way.
And I think one of
the other panelists
said it in building for a
business, kind of, you know.
WILL TURNBULL: Games are a
crowded space on every platform
right now.
But to the previous panel, if
you build a good community,
and you really work on your IP,
one thing that we find at Klei
is you can succeed anywhere.
And so the success
on one platform
can parlay over to another one.
And that's been a lot
of how "Don't Starve"
has succeeded on Google Play.
PETE ARDEN: Yeah, it's tough.
We started out with
the mission of creating
really immersive games,
the kind of games
that you would see on PC,
but on the mobile platform
six years ago.
And we were able to do that
with our first couple of games.
It's just becoming
increasingly hard.
Even though we
license games, it's
still very, very
competitive out there.
We're trying to solve that
problem a little bit by paying
for licenses to reach
these big communities that
are interested in
authentic immersive games.
But it's tough for us as well.
And yeah, you're right,
you can't count on--
nobody can count on featuring
anymore, I don't think.
PETR VODAK: And for us, a small
indie studio that started like,
five years ago.
And we are four.
So throughout the time, we
were focusing on innovation,
I mean, trying to come
up with something new
because it's a hard
thing, of course.
And you can sometimes
go to the dead end,
and go back, and try again.
But for us, it really worked.
I mean, the unique concepts--
we can undertake
the risks because we
don't have the costs.
So we are able to try
to focus on new things,
trying to find some new
concepts, something fresh.
That's what works for us.
SARAH THOMSON: Great.
And I think also,
too, all of you
have worked across
multiple platforms.
So what's that like, working
in a space that maybe you
developed some kind of success
story or track record on
and coming to new platforms,
whether that be mobile,
or VR, or any other platform?
Were there things that
transferred over for you?
Or were there
things that you had
to totally relearn or look--
have that paradigm shift?
Can you talk about that?
PETE ARDEN: It's interesting.
Some of our competitors
don't talk about their games
until they're ready
to release them.
They keep them in
a stealth mode.
And having come from PC
games and console games,
I was, as a
marketer, always very
used to doing long lead
build-up to a game launch,
not necessarily
spending a lot of money
but really developing
a community,
reaching out to people
who might be predisposed
to the kinds of games
that you're making.
We've taken the same
approach at Disruptor Beam.
We're not trying to
stay in stealth mode.
Even though we may soft launch
or do an early access program,
we really are trying to reach
out to the people who are,
we think, are going to
be inclined to our game.
And we were able to reach
hundreds of thousands
of those Star Trek
fans out there
when we launched "Star
Trek Timelines" last year
by going to events and
doing player gatherings,
community-driven events, really
connecting with users even
before the game was
out, and providing them
with a lot of content about
what we were up to, how
we were developing the game.
And that level of honesty and
authenticity with the players
has really paid off in
terms of their retention
and their spending.
RICARDO FISCHER:
I think part of it
is also build for the audience.
Know the audience.
When we started working on
"Terraria," one of the things
that we did is look at the
play patterns on mobile.
And they're very, very
different than PC.
People sit down at
PC to play for hours.
Mobile players are playing
online at a Starbucks.
So we decided to make
some things happen faster,
get players to the
core of the fun,
the crafting, the
discovery that happens
in the game at a much faster
pace to engage them sooner.
I think you need to
understand the audience.
And know that if you're
moving from another platform,
it is not the exact
same play patterns.
And while you don't have
to compromise your game,
you do have to address
it for the new audience.
WILL TURNBULL: Our games have
been on a lot of platforms.
"Don't Starve" started as
a browser game in 2012.
And one of the things that
we've used to great success
is early access.
And part of that is
slowly building community
and taking a lot of
feedback, both from analytics
and from the community,
to build better games.
And then when it comes
to new platforms,
initially, we were
pretty intimidated,
especially with mobile
because it was such a PC game.
And once we dove in, we found
that the experience really
worked.
And so my suggestion,
especially if you're
starting on another platform,
is the switching cost
isn't as big as you think it is.
And the game, especially if
it's fun on one platform,
will probably be fun
on another platform.
Clearly, there are differences
in how players play.
Like "Don't Starve," the day
cycles are eight minutes long.
Mobile play sessions should
be three minutes long.
And so how do you
make "Don't Starve"
a experience that a mobile
user can play comfortably?
That takes some
time and patience.
But the game itself
transfers over really
well from PC to mobile.
SARAH THOMSON:
Petr, did you want
to add more about your
experience with early access?
PETR VODAK: Well, yeah, I
mean, we offer early access.
Definitely, it's something
you should all do.
I mean, for us, we are
only creating mobile games,
so I can't compare.
But what we gained
through the early access
was for a real-time
of our game, one
of the things that
will help us a lot
was that we are able to
raise the game globally.
At the same time, all the
feedback we get wasn't public--
or weren't public.
So we were able to really
focus on all the stuff that
were given to us, all
the great feedback.
And we could test our
matchmaking real well.
We did load balancing
because we were
lucky to get a really good
position and a lot of downloads
through the early access.
So I mean, was one of the parts.
Of course, it helped us with
the cheating and hacking.
We were able to find out a
lot of issues with the game.
So we had this advantage, so
we can cope with that in time.
I mean, of course,
[? Boxx ?] as well.
And yeah, that's pretty much it.
SARAH THOMSON: Cool.
And actually, Jesse, I'd
love to hear your perspective
on what it's like being an
indie getting into VR and AR.
JESSE SCHELL: Yeah,
part of what's
really hard about being
indie going into VR
and AR is that it's really
tough making money in that space
right now because the number of
people using the system, buying
games is small.
It's bigger on mobile than it
is on the high-end platforms.
But on the flip side,
the folks on mobile
don't really want to
pay for very much.
So we're all waiting
for it to get big.
So I guess if you're indie,
thinking about going there,
I think it is a
good place to go.
But you've got to look at
it as a long-term investment
and think about the fact
that, yeah, in the beginning,
you might not be
making very much.
So like an example
of a game that we
did was our first VR
game that we put out
is this game called
"I Expect You to Die."
Now, we've been working
on it for three years.
And we started out just
putting a free level of it
up for free in the Oculus Share
store was the way we started.
And that got a lot of
really great feedback
and gave us the
confidence that we
could turn it into a
real game that we would
bring to multiple platforms.
But we had to really
take the long view on it.
And even now, I mean, like
that game is doing very well.
And it's very highly rated,
et cetera, et cetera.
I'm not sure it's going to
pay for itself until maybe
the end of this year.
So you have to take a little
bit of a long view with that.
So you want to look for
ways to be economical.
If you've got maybe some
mobile game that you think,
you know what, there's a
clever way I could bring this
to Tango, or a clever way I
could bring this to Daydream,
I think these are good
things to think about.
I mean, not everything
wants to port.
But some things actually
will port to VR pretty well.
And you can start to test
the waters with that,
and learn the medium, and
start to see if it's for you.
SARAH THOMSON: I think you bring
up a really interesting topic
that can apply across
the board for indies,
which is how do you have
long-term vision as an indie?
I think many indies are
just trying to figure out
how to keep the lights
on from month to month
or pay maybe their
5 to 10 employees.
So how do you have that
immediate first step in mind,
but also what's coming 5,
10 steps ahead as an indie,
especially as these
smaller bootstrap studios?
What's your advice there?
Anyone.
[CHUCKLES]
RICARDO FISCHER: I would say
weigh your choices carefully.
Rely on your
community and the data
that you're receiving from your
game to inform your decisions.
I think as game developers, we
tend to want to do what's cool.
But that doesn't always
resonate with the audience.
But there's a lot of avenues.
You can get Google
Analytics and early access
and all these great programs
that will inform your decisions
and help you make choices that
will return on the investment
that you're making.
I think that's a
great place to start.
JESSE SCHELL: And I guess one
thing I'll put out there--
not everybody always
talks about-- but the idea
of doing work-for-hire
projects as an indie
and making that part
of your ecosystem
and part of your business
model can work very well.
Not everybody chooses to do it.
It's how I've always
run my studio.
I've had 15 years of that,
where generally we're
doing somewhere
around 60% to 80%
of what we do is work-for-hire
projects with partners.
And then we try and
make those profitable,
and then try and do our
own IP along with that.
And if you don't
like work-for-hire,
well then you probably
shouldn't do it.
But it can be really nice.
You get to work with
some great people
and often work with
some great IPs.
And you get to sleep at
night because you know,
you know, just to be frank, even
if the game doesn't make money,
you get paid, right?
And everybody gets their salary
for working on that game.
So that can be a
thing to consider
if it works for your studio.
PETR VODAK: And you
learn a lot, right?
SARAH THOMSON: Mm.
PETE ARDEN: Yeah, this is
going to sound strange,
coming from a marketer speaking
to a room of developers.
But building in a certain
amount of modularity
into what you develop is
really important because what
we're finding, when we launched
"Star Trek Timelines," we aimed
squarely at Star Trek fans.
We got a lot of them early on.
The new-player
experience that we had
was really geared
toward someone who
was a true fan of Star Trek.
As time went on, costs started
to increase on the acquisition
side because we had run through
a lot of those initial users.
Now we're retooling our
new-player experience
to appeal more to a
gamer or someone looking
for some kind of
branded entertainment,
but maybe who has less intimate
knowledge of the Star Trek
lore-- is just looking
for a fun game.
And so we're doing
some experiments
now where we're able
to try different things
for the new audience
that's coming in.
So give yourself optionality.
Give yourself options.
There's a school of
thought where you just
go all in on one idea, and
you dedicate yourself to that,
and find an audience.
And that's absolutely
a great way to go.
There's an alternate way
of thinking-- or maybe side
by side in parallel-- where
you think about the options
that you give yourself
so that, as time goes on,
you can react to
market conditions
and a changing player base even.
JESSE SCHELL: Let me
just tell a quick story
about turning a
client relationship
into a piece of IP.
We'd been working with PBS
and the Fred Rogers Company
to make these "Daniel Tiger's
Neighborhood" games for really
little kids on websites.
And we'd done about
15 of these, but we
hadn't done any apps for them.
We'd just been doing
the website games.
And we had an idea for an app
that we thought would be--
an app you could
charge money for.
And we went to them and said,
this is a good idea for an app.
You should do this.
You should pay us to do this.
And they looked at it, and
they were like, mm, yeah,
it's not a bad idea.
But we don't really want
to pay you to do it.
We don't really have
an app budget for that.
And we looked at
each other and said,
well, what if we did
the investment on it?
And we'll pay for
the development.
But you guys put in the
license, and you guys
put in the marketing.
And then we'll split
the money on it.
And they were like,
well, actually,
that sounds pretty good
because we do like this idea.
But we just don't have a
budget for it right now.
SARAH THOMSON: That's cool.
JESSE SCHELL: And so
suddenly we turned a thing
where it had been totally
work-for-hire into a situation
where suddenly we're getting
a piece of the back end,
and we're driving the
relationship a little bit.
SARAH THOMSON: Yeah,
definitely the power
of relationship-building as an
indie with a larger partner.
And I think there's
stories across the board
here around that, too.
I mean, you guys work with--
PETR VODAK: Yeah.
SARAH THOMSON:
--Chillingo, right?
PETR VODAK: One more from me.
It was a super hard
decision for us.
We had decided to start
working on two games.
One we had decided
to self-publish.
to go with Chillingo.
And we had a previous experience
working with Chillingo,
and it was real well.
So we decided to
go again with them.
But with the self-published
game, we were like,
we need to make this
earlier because we
knew that the second
game is real big.
I mean, it was for
this small team.
At the time, there
was like 10 people
only on the team and working
on two games at the same time,
two free-to-play games with
all the full-scale features.
And so like, we had decided to
go with one of the games that
will self-publish.
It will help us to finance the
second game, and it worked out.
I mean, it was a small game.
It really was released like half
a year before the second one.
And it help us to overtake the
difficult times we had before
releasing the second game.
If we wouldn't do that, we
had to release the second game
much earlier.
And there wouldn't be really
at that quality and the state
we wanted to have it.
So it's a real help.
And regarding Chillingo,
it's something,
I mean, it's something
that you need to decide.
If you want to focus on
the game, for example,
or really on the development
of the game, and for example,
the marketing PR, some
QA stuff, utilization,
go-to-market stuff--
all these things if you are
something that you don't like,
and you don't want to do,
then go with a publisher.
I mean, we had experience with
some bad publishers, of course.
In case of Chillingo,
we were super happy.
And we are super happy
to work with them.
So--
SARAH THOMSON: Cool.
PETR VODAK: Yeah.
SARAH THOMSON: And I
think another challenging
point of being in indie, one
of the many things, is deciding
are you going to go
down the route of a paid
game versus free to play?
I think we all understand
how challenging paid content
is on mobile.
But there's a couple
of you here who
have had success around that.
So can you speak
to that success,
how that worked for you, and
what that looks like in terms
of long tail as well on mobile?
RICARDO FISCHER: So I
can speak to "Terraria."
"Terraria" is ongoing for
now three years on mobile.
And it's tremendously
successful.
I think a big credit
to the game goes
to having built a vibrant
community that is nurtured
on an ongoing basis.
Another aspect of it was
that we looked at "Terraria,"
and while it was a paid game,
we treated it as a game,
as a service.
We did continuous updates.
We introduced timed
content that would
allow us to do larger updates.
So we have a lot
of seasonal events.
And those are preset
into the game.
And that bought us time
to do longer updates that
required more effort on
the development side.
And the community still got
new stuff to play around with.
We got the time we needed to
give them the larger content
updates.
So I think you can still
have success in those games.
You do have to kind of treat
them as, in a lot of ways,
like free-to-play plays.
And you have to be super
careful with the community.
WILL TURNBULL: Yeah,
for "Don't Starve,"
it's a $4.99 app,
which is pretty
expensive in the mobile world.
But we also run
it like a service.
And we're both constantly
monitoring all our views
and seeing if we can find trends
in terms of what players are
looking for, whether
it be different control
schemes or different
language support,
and then also just perennially
adding content to the game
and feeding the fiction, both
on mobile and also on PC.
And having that community
play into each other
has been really successful
in building long tail.
Also, just knowing your
game is super important.
Do you have a game that people
are going to come back and play
day after day, or
a game where you
have to do something super
splashy to bring them back in?
Knowing your game and
understanding your game
can help you feel build,
like, a long tail.
SARAH THOMSON: And
actually, Will, I
want to quickly touch on a
really interesting comment
that you made when we
were talking leading up
to this panel about your
unique perspective on piracy
because as we all know,
that is an ongoing issue
for content on Android.
WILL TURNBULL: We love piracy.
[CHUCKLES] Piracy is great.
Piracy basically proves out that
there's demand for your game.
And the way that
we look at pirates
is those are just
customers that we're
going to bring in someday.
We're either going to make the
game more convenient to buy
in a region, or we're
going to bring in something
that they need or
want and they're
going to come in and buy.
So one of the things that we
saw in PC and we see on Android
is our piracy rates are high.
We have hundreds of thousands of
daily active users of pirates.
But the beauty of it is
that those players convert,
and we can see them
convert in our analytics.
And so our goal as a
studio is to grow our IP.
And that means people
playing our games.
We'll make money eventually
from those users,
whether it be on "Don't Starve,"
or it'd be on the next game.
Trying to seal off your game
and keep people from playing it
isn't going to be a strategy
that wins in the long term.
SARAH THOMSON: Great, thank you.
And on the flip side,
let's talk about being
an indie in the
free-to-play space, which
I think in some ways can
be even more challenging
because then you're
really coming up
against the big titans, right,
you have astronomical UA
budgets and big teams fueling
the community side of things
and the social side of things.
So those who are doing
the free-to-play side
of the business, what's
that been like for you?
And how have you managed
to be successful there?
PETE ARDEN: It's hard.
It's really hard.
It's a lot of content.
We do a lot of content
updates in the game.
That's what drives the community
to participate, ultimately
to spend.
But we don't just do
it inside the game.
The previous panel, they
talked a lot about community,
about servicing the
community on social channels,
giving them updates
about what's going on,
bringing them back in.
Maybe this week you're not
interested in the event
that's going on.
But next week on
Facebook we'll post
about the next one
with maybe some
of your favorite characters
that you'll come back in on.
But yeah, there's a lot of
pressure from all sides on free
to play.
It's about really having a very
robust content plan and then
a very active dialogue with
your players about what
features do they want to see and
what you're capable of doing.
We only have a fairly small
team on "Star Trek Timelines"
relative to the size of the
game in terms of players.
And it's because we do as
much as we can to introduce
new features all the time.
And sometimes you have
to sit back and go,
I guess we're not going to
do an actual visible feature
release for four
months because we
have to plan and build up to it
with underlying features that
get us there.
So sometimes we don't
have big feature updates,
which is not great.
But we keep the content
coming constantly.
SARAH THOMSON: Petr, did you
have anything to add there?
PETR VODAK: Well, I already
said is that in our case,
it's really trying to come
up with something unique.
So basic thing is the
fun of the game itself.
Then, for example, in
case of "WarFriends,"
it's [INAUDIBLE] real-time
[INAUDIBLE] game.
And it's also game that you want
to watch and don't always play.
So there is tons of content
being shared every day.
And the game is really--
it's physical based.
So there is a lot of
fun things happening.
Sometimes it's not that
fun for us, you know?
But yeah, so this will help us
to build a community, to build
a [INAUDIBLE] about a game.
So that works for us.
JESSE SCHELL: I know one
of our rules of thumb
with free to play is if
you can't look at the game
and say, oh, I can imagine us
getting a million downloads,
like even considering
free to play
is just crazy because
you just-- you
need so many players in order
to make the thing profitable.
SARAH THOMSON: Yeah,
community is key.
And I think, Pete,
you guys have done
a really great job of really
staying true to the brand
with Star Trek.
And talk about how that sort
of resonates for your game.
PETE ARDEN: Sure, yeah.
It's one of our cores, one
of our values for the company
is authenticity in how we deal
with each other internally,
but also how we deal with our
IP holders, our licensors,
and the community
itself, the fans.
And by showing that we are
real fans of these IPs,
too, we're able to connect the
real Star Trek fans on a level
that they haven't seen
on mobile and they really
haven't seen very
often on PC, either.
So people who are looking for
the best Star Trek video game
are often coming
to our game and not
going to some of the PC games
or the other mobile games
because we have the
richness of content.
I will say, though,
that "Star Trek
Timelines" was designed in some
sense as a single-player game.
That content furnace
that we have is--
we have to spend a lot of
time and energy on that.
Our next game is based
on "The Walking Dead."
And that one is a
much more social game.
That one is where to take
the pressure off of us,
we want to have the players
generate a lot of the content.
The intrigue, the meta
game-- all of that
is, when you're
designing a game,
if you can get players to
generate the content for you,
you're saving a lot
of money on that.
SARAH THOMSON: OK, I'm going
to ask one more question.
And then if anyone has
any questions, please
feel free to line up at
the microphones there.
So what's kept you
in the indie space?
I mean, you're all
really talented.
I'm sure you could get
a job anywhere you like.
What keeps you indie?
Why, despite all of the
challenges and how hard it is?
JESSE SCHELL: It's super fun.
[CHUCKLING]
Right?
You can do things the way you
want when you want to do it.
And, like, there's
nothing better than that.
That's super fun.
SARAH THOMSON: Yeah.
PETR VODAK: Yeah, that's right.
PETE ARDEN: I mean, one of
our strategies at Disruptor--
being another one of them-- is
that we're tightly integrated
between development
and publishing.
We don't have
third-party studios.
We do it all in-house
in the same building.
That cuts down on
communication time.
It increases the understanding
between development
and publishing.
It really helps us.
And that is why
although we're growing,
it's always going to have that
sort of speed and agility.
And that's what I
like about indie-- is
no one's off somewhere a
couple thousand miles away
making decisions about
what we're doing.
We're doing it collectively
together, ourselves.
WILL TURNBULL: The freedom--
the freedom's awesome.
We have the ability to
course-correct dramatically
on a week-to-week
basis and do what
we see best for the
company at the moment,
rather than be beholden
to some other stakeholder.
JESSE SCHELL: Yeah, I've started
working on toy robots lately.
And you know who can say no?
Nobody.
[LAUGHING]
SARAH THOMSON:
Well, there you go.
What more do you need?
Yep.
Great.
Thanks, guys.
OK, let's take the
first question here.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a question
for the guys that
said they do work for hire.
I'd like to know how do you
kick start a work-for-hire team?
How do you build your first
portfolio of clients on so on?
JESSE SCHELL: Yeah, it
comes through networking,
for the most part.
For me, in the beginning, I
used to work at The Walt Disney
Company.
And I had left, and
I was off teaching.
And then I ended up
starting my own studio.
And my initial
work-for-hire projects
were all from people that I
used to know through The Disney
Company.
And but then gradually, I
got to know other people.
So it really is, so much
of it is just about people
knowing you and
getting to trust you.
And it can happen a lot of ways.
It's part of the reason
why I speak publicly a lot.
One of the biggest
projects we ever got
was someone called me up and
said, I saw this talk you gave.
I thought it was great.
How'd you like to do this
multimillion-dollar deal?
And I'm like, oh, I guess I'm
glad I did that talk, you know?
AUDIENCE: Nice.
SARAH THOMSON: No, I'm too
busy building toy robots.
JESSE SCHELL: That's right.
[CHUCKLING]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: This question
mainly for Will but also
for anyone else.
So as an indie, you've got
more constrained resources.
And mobile people are kind of
expecting constant updates.
But if you're making
premium games,
you've got to stop that and
move on to your next project.
So how do you balance the two?
And have you got
any tricks for that?
WILL TURNBULL: Yeah.
So one of things is with
Klei and with our games,
they continue to sell.
And the more that we
fuel those communities,
we can keep on
working on those games
because we keep on finding
more customers to buy.
So "Don't Starve" is a game
that's four and a half years
in, and we're still
working on DLCs
and adding content and
adding free updates.
So there's an important
moment with a game
and watching a game that's
the game has run its course,
and you need to move on.
But as long as you see
that people are still
resonating and still purchasing,
it's fine to stay in there
and keep on building
out a content for it.
RICARDO FISCHER: Adding on
to what Will said, I agree.
On "Terraria," you would
think that every time you
do a content update, you're
doing it for existing users.
But every time we did that,
we saw spikes on downloads
on a consistent basis.
It was like clockwork.
So if your game is working and
you continue to support it,
you're going to see continued
success, especially if you're
building that community
because those people who
love the game evangelize
it to other people
or buy it on new platforms.
So you don't necessarily have
to move on to the next game.
There's obviously
a point in time
at which you reduce
the team size
and start working
on your next thing.
But it's not a firearm
for good business.
It's nurture it and
carry it forward.
WILL TURNBULL:
Another thing, too,
is those users that do stay in
the game and see those updates
or remember that you
kept on adding content,
and when you come to
making your next game,
they'll be more excited about
buying it because they're like,
oh man, I bought
this game for $2.99,
and it kept on adding stuff.
So not only are you servicing
your current customers,
but you're setting the
table for whatever's next.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SARAH THOMSON: Great.
AUDIENCE: Well, first of all,
I wanted to say, thank you,
Jesse Schell, for that book
that you wrote about game design
because when you said, how do
you become a game designer?
You just gotta say,
I'm a game designer,
and start making games.
So thanks.
I wouldn't have done
that without you.
JESSE SCHELL: All right.
AUDIENCE: And (CHUCKLING) then
the question that I have is now
in mobile markets, I mean, we've
seen the growth that it's had.
It's immense.
It still makes more money
than consoles and PC combined,
from the research
that I've done.
But when you're seeing
big players like EA,
like Nintendo getting
into the mobile market--
and you guys are not,
like, brand-new in these.
You guys have had some success.
But for, like, people
that are trying
to break into the
mobile market, like,
what would you say is
good advice for somebody
who doesn't have the
recognition or the connections
even to, like, be able to work
with other studios and stuff
like that?
JESSE SCHELL: I'd say you better
do something really different.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JESSE SCHELL: Really different.
So different that people are
going to want to talk about it
and write about it and share
about it and all of that
because if you're
not doing that,
it's buying a lottery ticket.
You might win.
AUDIENCE: Right.
JESSE SCHELL: But there's not
a lot of strategy for winning.
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
WILL TURNBULL: One
of the big benefits
of being an indie
studio that starts on PC
is that we end up
being some of the best
products on mobile
because the AAA games--
a PC can't make the same leap.
So one of the big
benefits that we've seen
is the types of
experiences that we've
been able to build
on PC translate
into being some of the most
interesting and deep pieces
of content on mobile.
So I'm not saying
necessarily start on PC.
But that can be a big advantage,
and especially if you build--
for us, our story was we built
a big followership there,
and it followed us onto mobile.
And we saw a lot of players
come and buy the game again
because they liked it so
much that they wanted to have
the same experience on the go.
And I think the same's
true for "Terraria," too.
RICARDO FISCHER:
Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
SARAH THOMSON: I think from
the platform perspective,
when we're looking
at new games that
are launching from developers
that are fairly obscure,
I think quality is
always number one.
And it feels like an
obvious thing to say.
And it doesn't
mean that your game
has to be super
complex or super deep.
It can be a very
simple experience.
But if you've really
gone that extra mile
to make sure that your
art is super polished,
and your UI is very clean,
and it's very intuitive,
I think really sticking to
those kind of basic principles
will get you off
on the right foot.
And then I think being
at events like this,
where the indie community
is quite tightly knit.
And if you're able to go
to a few of the parties,
and introduce yourself
to other indies,
and share your game with
them, usually other indies
love to see indie games.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
SARAH THOMSON: And so
if you create a buzz
within that community, that
does tend to trickle up
to us more often than not.
You'd be surprised
because indies
love to support each other.
So I would definitely
encourage you to do that.
And I think you're on
the right foot being here
and asking the right questions.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much, everybody.
Oh, sorry.
PETR VODAK: I have
one more thing to add.
For us, what would work
is to release the game
as soon as possible.
Don't wait.
Don't try to over-polish.
Just go for it.
Don't be afraid to fail.
And release and go
for another game.
And you will learn a lot.
So every other game will be
much better and much better.
Do it.
JESSE SCHELL: And a thing
that a lot of new indies
don't think about is if you
come out with a bad game,
no one will know.
[CHUCKLING]
Right, that's your whole
problem is that no one knows.
You can come out with a good
game, and no one will know.
But if you come out
with a bad game,
definitely no one
will know, right?
So, like, I talked
about the success
we had with "I Expect You
to Die" in the Oculus share
market.
That was the second one.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow.
JESSE SCHELL: The first one
we did was a lot rougher.
And we put it out.
And everyone was like,
meh, who cares, right?
And no one even knows
that that happened.
But we still believed in it.
And so we, like, made a more
polished and better version.
And then it was over threshold.
And then everybody
talked about it.
So you shouldn't
be shy about when
you've got a new
thing you want to try,
put out early versions of it.
And then just keep spinning
it up until it's good.
It's a weird way
to have to think.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
I was kind of afraid of that,
actually, because I was like,
it's my first impression.
I don't want to come out and
have this game that's like, oh,
everybody's like, well,
this sucks, you know?
Or whoever plays it,
like, the 5 or 10 people--
JESSE SCHELL: No,
like four dudes.
Well, who cares, right?
[CHUCKLING]
Like, who cares?
You can find five other people
who don't like your game.
It's no problem.
[LAUGHING]
PETR VODAK: Actually,
we spent three years
with a game that sucks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PETR VODAK: That's why
you have to spend, like,
three months with such game.
So--
AUDIENCE: OK.
SARAH THOMSON: Yeah.
PETR VODAK: --no worries.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you guys so much.
Appreciate it.
SARAH THOMSON: OK, let's have
one more question over here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So for indie gamers,
developers, the user positioning
is super important.
So do you think
the China market is
another channel for you guys?
And do you have any
intention and plan for it
for China markets?
WILL TURNBULL: China
is our biggest market
worldwide for "Don't Starve."
And you would
think, hey, this is
a game that was designed
for a Western audience.
And what ended up happening,
especially went to mobile,
is we find an avenue where
Chinese players could
legitimately buy the game.
And then through
tracking our data, which
I can't stress enough, we
noticed that suddenly there was
a surge in Chinese purchasers.
And then we went and
positioned it last year such
that it could grow
rapidly in China.
So Chinese players
are definitely
really interested
in indie games.
And so doing proper
localization,
but once you see a signal in a
market like that, jump on it.
[CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
SARAH THOMSON: Great.
OK, thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
And that actually wraps
our day, our Developer Day
here for Google.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
And hopefully you
all are walking away
with a little gem of wisdom.
And enjoy the rest of your week.
Enjoy GDC.
[MUSIC PLAYING]